next question is from Katie who said do
you think that challenges improve a
person's character do you believe in no
pain no gain every time I think about
this idea of building character I'm
reminded of calvin and hobbes where
every time as a kid i grew up reading
calvin and hobbes by Bill Watterson very
often Calvin dad when Calvin was forced
to shovel snow or go camping and it
rains or whatever his dad would say that
this is all building character and every
time I'm asked about whether challenges
build or improve a person's character
I've reminded of that I don't really buy
into the concept of no pain no gain when
it comes to like working out in fact the
more i read seems like actually you
really shouldn't be in too much pain
like yes of course exertion will cause
some discomfort but increasingly we know
that maxing out weightlifting to a
weight where you can only do one rep is
really not particularly healthy or just
going to failure i mean there's yeah
reports on that a lot of different ways
in which it doesn't seem it seems like
pain may be bad actually when it comes
to a lot of that when it comes to sort
of like life stuff and challenges I
think there is no doubt that if
everything is always super easy you will
probably lack some personal development
that you could or definitely would have
I would say if you experience anything
from setbacks too difficult
circumstances now exactly what that
means for each person could probably be
debated right so what I would say it
would be really great for everybody to
have everyone that they love in their
family died within a week of each other
because it would be really difficult and
you would develop your foot your
character obviously I don't believe that
right that that seems like an insane
thing to say but I think that there's no
doubt that if you are used to getting
through school really really easily and
all of a sudden you get to college and
hey you know what tougher than you
expected it's stressful you're having to
now manage getting a lot of work done
and a lot of reading done maybe you're
also working part-time to support
yourself there's no doubt that that
would be a difficult situation for many
people but it's probably a really good
experience to have for later in life
when you may have many things to manage
or there may be issues that come up
unexpectedly and you have that
experience there's an 18 to 22 year olds
for example having managed issues that
relate to time management financial
issues etc it probably does help to
prepare you for issues in the real world
I mean I think it really depends because
if it's something like shoveling a
driveway or mowing the lawn every day I
don't think that's really building
character as you referenced and is it
even that difficult it's not even that
so difficult no but I think if you let's
say you grow up in poverty or something
and then you're able to come out of it
when you're older I think you you do
build character because you're able to
emphasize with what what that was like
and help people along and make the same
journey that you went with and so in
that way I think challenges do make you
stronger this whole no pain no gain
thing I think it makes sense in some
respects because you should be able to
push your comfort level I for example is
never too good with public speaking but
I improved just by doing it and without
making that effort without making that
extra step in putting myself out there I
wouldn't have gotten to where I am I
think the main point is it's undeniable
that if no one ever did anything that
was a challenge or uncomfortable we
would have so many people who never
altima tlie find areas of life that they
excel in and make significant
contributions to society through and
that's sort of where I end up on it of
creating really really harsh situations
just for the sake of it and maybe that's
sort of an adrenaline adrenaline rush
for adventure tourism types and stuff
like that that's not exactly what I'm
talking about but I think I tend to
agree with you overall or you just have
a group of people who can't really
emphasize with those below them and the
socio and economic ladder yeah people
like our president currently yes indeed
yes indeed I think that Donald Trump
would be a very different person and
arguably someone who would make a much
better president had he experienced some
of what Pat is talking about and I know
that he only got a small loan of a
million dollars from his dad and that
that's very small compared to some other
people and legitimately he did have I
believe it's a brother who committed
suicide and he spoke about Anderson
Cooper about that that's absolutely a
huge personal trauma family setback etc
but I think by and large we sort of
understand the way in which having a
different upbringing would have changed
who Donald Trump is
person bonus show is next david
pakman.com slash membership to sign up
and get instant access